وينضم الينا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز دويري اهلا بك
سيد لواء اهميه هذا الصاروخ البالستي
الروسي الجديد ضمن الترسانه الروسيه
الضخمه
يعني اهميته بناء على المواصفات التي تم
نشرها حول هذا الصاروخ هذا الصاروخ المدى
الاقصى يصل 18 الف كيلو متر اي بمعنى اخر
يستطيع ان يطال اهداف في عمق الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الامر الاخر من ميزات
هذا الصاروخ انه يعمل على ثلاثه مراحل
يحمل عشره رؤوس نوويه القيمه الاجبيه او
القدره الاجماليه التدميريه 40 ميجا طن
يعني اكثر من الف ضعف
للقنبله التي القيت على هيروشيما او
نجازاكي وهو قريب من قنبله القيصر التي تم
تفجيرها في 63 في عام 63 من القرن الماضي
سرعته اكثر من 20خ وبالتالي
من المواصفات سمي بالشيطان سمي بملك
الصواريخ سمي بصاروخ يوم القيامه لا يوجد
وسائل يمكن التعامل كان روسيا عندما قدمت
هذا الصاروخ تقول لا يستطيع احد ان يمارس
الضغط او التهديد او الابتزاز النووي على
على روسيا وبالتالي هو اصبح الحامل
الرئيسي للثالوث الاستراتيجي النووي ولكن
يبقى سلاح ردع وليس سلاح الاستخدام لكن ما
هو ما هي قدرات الجانب الاخر الجانب الاخر
الجانب الامريكي لا يتحدث كثيرا عن
منظومات الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه عابره
القارات علما ان السنوات الاخيره اثبتت ان
هناك لا اقول تفوقا ساحقا انما هناك تقدم
في التقنيه الصواريخ
سواء كانت ضد الجو او الصواريخ عابره
للقارات تميل لصالح الجانب الروسي وهذا ما
اثار حفيظه الكثير من الخبراء والمحللين
الاستراتيجيين الامريكيه نقرا في تاكيد
موسكو انها ابلغت واشنطن مسبقا باجراء
التجربه صاروخيه رغم تعليقها العمل
بمعاهده ستارت
يعني هناك هناك امور حتى لو تم التعليق في
حول ستارت وتم ايقاف عمليات التفتيش
والتحقق والتاكد المتبادل حول المستودعات
وحول الاجراءات هناك اجراءات لابد لروسيا
ان تبلغ امريكا وامريكا تبلغ روسيا سواء
في حاله اجراء تجارب على صواريخ متطوره
تحمل اسلحه نوويه
متعدده الرؤوس او اجراء مناورات ذات صبغه
استراتيجيه وهذا الامر ليس من الفتره
الحاليه هذا حتى في ظل الحرب البارده كان
هناك خط ساخن ما بين الاتحاد السوفيتي وما
بين امريكا ويتم ابلاغ كل جانب يبلغ
الجانب الاخر حتى تكون الامور واضحه ولا
تفسر الامور بطريقه خاطئه شكرا لك